we have a Republican governor here in
Massachusetts I've mentioned him before
his name is Charlie Baker and he just
signed into law a bill giving every
resident of Massachusetts the option to
vote by mail in the fall and in the
primaries leading up to the fall if
indeed that is what we want to do now I
have not hidden this from folks since
the start of the corona virus pandemic I
did not vote for Charlie Baker I'm not a
Republican but he has been a Republican
who has done a good job a big picture on
the corona virus and he's doing a lot of
the right things so if I wanted to
criticize certainly he could have
started stay at home a little earlier he
could have talked about the importance
of wearing masks earlier but
Massachusetts is one of the few states
that has actually gotten the virus what
we would call under control as of right
now and this may change as cases
continue to explode in many states my
belief is that at some point because you
can't block travel between states or at
least it doesn't appear as though you
can because of the Constitution we are
going to have a bleed over effect I am
fully expecting that as we get into late
summer and early fall Massachusetts will
start to see more cases but as of right
now we've seen dramatic declines in
cases and much of it has been under or
related to Republican Governor Charlie
Baker's leadership and likewise we now
have a statewide vote by mail which is
extremely important and completely and
obviously logical given the corona virus
pandemic the Secretary of State website
now says quote in July meaning yesterday
a new law was passed to allow registered
voters in Massachusetts to vote by mail
in any twenty twenty election with no
excuse needed as required by the new law
a vote by mail application will be
mailed to every person who was
registered to vote by July 1 and who had
not already requested an absentee ballot
for the state primary or for all
elections this year a second mailing
will be sent out in September to all
voters who have not already applied for
vote by mail for the November election
the applications are pre addressed to
your local
official and no postage is necessary so
they're not just sending ballots around
the fear-mongering from the trumpian
right is you just start sending ballots
places anybody could fill them in and
return them and voter fraud and a little
that all that stuff the reality is what
they're doing is they're taking the list
of registered voters and sending them
applications for absentee ballots which
you still must return they must be
delivered to the local election office
no later than four business days before
the election this is the right move this
is simple just do it
come on States just do it it's the right
thing to do it's the safe thing to do
and the the problem is great
Massachusetts is doing it Biden is going
to win Massachusetts easily in other
words what I mean is the states that
will be close where people may be scared
to vote in person because of the
pandemic those are the states where you
might actually see a different outcome
if there isn't vote by mail and many of
those are the states that are not
interested in doing vote by mail now
fortunately there are important states
that have done it I believe Pennsylvania
and Ohio Arizona Texas has temporarily
said fear of catching the virus counts
as a valid reason to vote absentee maybe
Iowa but this needs to be something
every state does and and in fact when we
look at Trump careening down Hill in the
polls and we look at everything that's
going on his reelection depends on yes
lying about the state of the economy
lying about the state of the pandemic
but it also depends on suppressing the
vote and not allowing vote-by-mail is
something that could in very material
terms dissuade people from voting at all
back to Charlie Baker in Massachusetts
just just a little bit because I
anticipate some of the emails I might
receive I have no delusions that Charlie
Baker is the height of progressivism
he's a former health insurance CEO he's
like a Mitt Romney type Republican
essentially but it shouldn't be unusual
that you have a governor who listens to
doctors in science in other words what's
notable about the fact that Charlie
Baker a Republican governor has
mostly handled the virus correctly is
that it is unusual to have a Republican
governor who says I'm going to do what
the doctors recommend we have a pandemic
I'm going to make decisions based on
science and the medical community I'm
gonna close things I'm going to allow
vote-by-mail for everybody the reason
that this is newsworthy the reason that
I'm talking in these terms of we have a
Republican governor who has actually
managed this pretty well is that it's so
rare when you look at governor's like
Ron de santis in Florida I mean just off
the deep end Greg Abbott in Texas and in
particular it actually Abbott has come
back to reality a little bit saying we
need masks we should probably slow down
or stop on bars the Lieutenant Governor
there dan patrick has been particularly
crazy
you've got doug ducey in arizona and
many many others that is why it is so
notable that a republican governor like
Charlie Baker has done the right thing
now I have some criticisms of what
Charlie Baker is doing I believe it is
too early to do indoor dining phase
three in Massachusetts includes casinos
and movie theaters I just disagree I'm
not going to any of those I've decided
I'm comfortable with outdoor dining
right now I'm not going inside I mean
it's just it's not necessary it's summer
there are articles that are linking
card-present restaurant receipts
receipts to increased case numbers so it
does seem like the indoor dining is a
problem I think it's an unnecessary risk
right now particularly when we don't
mean listen there may not even be a gap
between wave 1 & 2 but we're
anticipating more cases in the fall so I
disagree with Baker on that I think it's
too early big picture managing it well
vote-by-mail for everybody in
Massachusetts absolutely the right
decision I'm glad to see it we now just
need states where it'll be closed
between Trump and Biden to adopt it as
well